a majority in the European Parliament
has given the green light to new
copyright rules fit for the digital age
the rules will ensure that rights and
responsibilities of intellectual
property now apply to the online world
asleep tighter in under hunt oil or
pichia school to a good sweatin on this
initiative our sporting frantic
monopolist new velocity as leaked toyota
opened under hunt owns of an oval
patiently achieve and in drinkin fanatic
in short soupy the copyright directive
is the result of negotiations between
political groups in the European
Parliament and EU governments Internet
platforms will now be liable for content
that uses upload and will have an
incentive to pay authors musicians and
content creators fairly but the report
was not universally welcomed tech giants
fiercely opposed the directive and some
said it would endanger creativity and
freedom of expression online this text
will change the Internet as we know it
and to you'll have vast negative effect
on the way people share and declare
knowledge
spyfu nuts Towson mentioning ham and
decent often and the gig visa reform
demonstrate frenemy yawnin have unabated
shown gig applauded filter on her she'll
know me huh design dia at Brighton
protest King and ee h t- m eps
acknowledged these phase and supported
lighter regulation and exemptions for
startups or non-commercial platforms
such as Wikipedia memes gifts and other
creative works for the purposes of
criticism review or parody
can still be shared by everyone the text
also ensures a ferret revenue for the
press in the future large online
platforms and news aggregators will be
encouraged to strike their licensing
agreements with artists and media houses
new snippets can continue to be shared
lacunae middle oppressor dodger safe on
rippin off so Kartini are blue the press
liebherr cotton you are occasionally
said don't go girl da wikipedia da
youtube we know they play that for
Michonne Parliament has driven to ensure
the protection of the rights of authors
while safeguarding freedoms of all
intimate users